source énergétique vous avez la parole
merci beaucoup commentant ce que vous
souhaitez s'ennuie je vous coupe
bon alors je vais essayer de faire
relativement court avant de répondre à
cette question on va faire comme dans
les bons devoir de philo un tout petit
peu de définition des termes qu'on est
en train de manipuler en général quand
on parle de croissance surtout avec des
économistes
on parle de croissance de la production
économique mesurée par le pib oui c'est
bien de ça dont on parle quand on
regarde la façon conventionnelle qu'on a
d'aborder cette question l'économie tel
qu'on l'a enseigné à l'école il ya
essentiellement deux facteurs de
production c'est à dire qu'il ya des
gens qui travaillent et il ya du capital
humain et vous mettez ça dans votre
grande marmite et il vous en ressort une
production lorsque l'ingénieur ou le
physicien vous fera remarquer c'est que
il manque un ingrédient dans cette
marmite qui s'appelle les ressources
naturelles
puisque les lunettes que vous portez
sont constitué d'atomes que nous sommes
allés chercher dans la nature
le micro dans lequel je parlais
constitué d'atomes que nous sommes allés
chercher dans la nature et d'une manière
générale tout ce que vous voyez autour
de vous ne sont rien d'autre que des
ressources naturelles bruts ou
transformés par notre activité dont vous
avez besoin de cet ingrédient dans la
marmite du coup ça veut dire que dans
les facteurs limitants de l'économie ce
qu'on a coutume d'appeler la gestion des
ressources rares vous pouvez
effectivement trouvé le nombre de gens
qui travaillent et là on vient de vivre
une crise dans laquelle c'est la
suppression d'une partie des gens qui
travaillent qui a causé le problème
économique
enfin la suppression qui justement de
leur aptitude à travailler vous pouvez
avoir un problème de défaut de capital
humain qu'une usine puis etc mais vous
pouvez aussi avoir un défaut de
ressources naturelles par exemple si
vous n'avez plus de sable
eh bien vous ne faites plus de béton
avec du sable
même si vous avez des usines pour faire
du béton et des gens prêts à travailler
dans les usines pour faire du béton et
des banquiers très généreux avec les
gens qui fabriquent du béton alors dans
cet accès aux ressources naturelles
vous avez un on va dire un élément qui
permet de les prendre dans leur ensemble
d'une façon un peu simplificatrice qui
est l'énergie
pourquoi est-ce que l'énergie permet de
représenter d'accès aux ressources
naturelles parce que l'énergie en
physique avant qu avant que l'énergie
soit des kilowattheures sur une facture
ou une discussion sur le prix de
l'électricité l'énergie en physique
c'est la grandeur qui caractérise le
changement d'état d'un système
exactement qui quantifie le changement
d'état d'un système dont
dès que vous avez quelque chose qui
change autour de vous vous avez de
l'énergie qui entrent en jeu et plus le
changement est important plus la
quantité d'énergie qui entrent en jeu
est importante donc l'énergie c'est la
quantification du changement dans le
monde physique
c'est ça sa définition or à les extraire
des atomes de fer de cuivre ou à les
extraire des poissons de la mer c'est
toujours une opération de transformation
et derrière transformer du minerai de
fer en petite cuillère c'est aussi une
opération de transformation donc
l'énergie peut être considéré comme un
marqueur agrégatifs de l'ensemble de nos
flux de production et de la capacité à
accéder aux ressources
oui si je vais creusé sous la maison de
la radio dans un mètre cube de terre que
j'ai extrait je vais trouver tous les
éléments du tableau de mendeleïev mais
92 y seront mais à des concentrations
qui seront plus ou moins importantes et
en fonction de la quantité d'énergie que
je peux consacrer à leur extraction de
ce maître cubes de terre j'ai accès à un
plus grand 1 1 plus ou moins grand
nombre que définissent hollande hergies
aujourd'hui effectivement elle est
réductrice
on la voit je voulais des prix j'ai la
facture d'électricité se tape sur la
figure pour savoir si on va remplacer un
réacteur nucléaire par des éoliennes
mais en fait c'est le fond du problème
c'est que l'énergie c'est pas ça
l'énergie c'est la capacité à
transformer et il se trouve que quand
vous regardez ce qui se passe depuis
deux siècles
physiquement nous avons mis au travail
des machines qui sont venu suppléer non
seulement suppléer remplacer notre corps
donc il ya deux siècles l'essentiel de
la force productive été fournies par
brusque et puis progressivement nous
avons rajouté des travailleurs
artificielle qui s'appelle des machines
qui se nourrissent d'énergie et qui sont
aujourd'hui en fait venue produire à
notre place si transitoirement la france
a eu un pib plus important que celui de
la chine c'est pas parce qu'on était
plus nombreux on n'a jamais été plus
nombreux que les chinois c'est parce
qu'on avait plus de machines et la
quantité totale de machines que vous
avez sur terre aujourd'hui à multiplier
la puissance musculaire des hommes des 8
milliards d'hommes par un facteur de
quelques centaines pour aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment les machines qui
produisent et tant que vous n'avez pas
de problème de nombre de gens pour
piloter les machines ce qui nous est
arrivé pendant la crise du coc vide ou
que vous n'avez pas de problème pour
remplacer ces machines d alimenter en
ressources naturelles parce qu'un four à
verre pour l'alimenter avec du sable et
du carbonate de calcium sinon ils vous
produit pas de verre et bien vous vous
rendez compte que le premier facteur
limitant de l'économie industrielle dans
laquelle nous sommes même si on a
beaucoup d'emplois de services en fait
on est lors d'une économie industrielle
c'est la quantité d'énergie et
particulièrement la quantité de pétrole
dont on dispose donc si vous regardez ce
qui se passe depuis des décennies depuis
qu'on a des statistiques à peu près
correct sur ce qui se passe dans le
monde
vous vous rendez compte que le premier
facteur limitant de la production
économique c'est la quantité d'énergie
dont on dispose et donc ça veut dire que
pour demain
si vous avez moins d'énergie de façon à
poser ou de façon délibérée
vous aurez moins de machines au travail
et donc vous aurez au sens où on ne
compte traditionnellement un pib qui se
contracte donc la réponse à la question
quelle croissance pour demain
ma vision de la faire c'est que à un
moment ou un autre ce ne sera plus une
croissance au sens économique
conventionnel du terme ce sera une
décroissance
par ailleurs quand vous regardez les
statistiques européennes vous vous
rendez compte que cette décroissance on
y est entré deux fait depuis 2007
c'est pas un hasard et c'est pas la
crise des subprimes qui a causé la
récession c'est le stress sur
l'approvisionnement pétrolier mondial
qui a causé la crise des subprimes on
avait déjà un endettement qui avait
commencé à croître depuis le premier
choc pétrolier qui est déjà un premier
changement de vitesse sur l'extraction
pétrole dans le monde
avant les chocs pétroliers le pétrole
crois c'est à raison de 8 % par an dans
le monde
on extrayait chaque année 8 % de pétrole
en plus que l'année précédente après les
chocs pétroliers ça descend à 1 %
donc c'est un énorme choc physique et
sacré l'endettement dans tous les pays
occidentaux et en 2006 vous avez un
deuxième choc pétrolier qui est que la
production de pétrole conventionnel dans
le monde tout ce qui n'est pas le
pétrole de schiste et les sables
bitumineux passe par un maximum et se
met à décliner et ça de nouveau ça vous
donne un énorme coup de pied dans la
montagne de dettes accumulées et en
europe
l'approvisionnement pétrolier il est
partie pour se contracter à partir de
maintenant la quantité de pétrole qu'on
peut rentrer en europe et donc mon pari
à moi pour les quelques décennies qui me
reste à vivre et pour les quelques
décennies supplémentaires mes enfants
vont devoir vivre c'est que nous
n'allons pas devoir réfléchir dans un
monde en croissance mais dans un monde
en contraction
alors ça peut être très désagréable pour
faire et dire mon compte d'une
contraction plus tôt que des croissants
ou parce que j'avais je parle de flux
physiques d'accord alors après on peut
toujours décider qu'on valorise la
connaissance 50% plus chaque année et
avoir un pib qui facialement crois que
si on veut mais ça devient une affaire
de convention par contre ce que je crois
c'est que l'énergie se contractant les
flux physiques par définition se
contractait puisque l'énergie c'est les
flux physiques et donc de fait la
quantité de mètres carrés de tables de
chaises et ses mots
l'eau un peu d'efficacité énergétique
mais dans les ingénieurs vous disent que
ça peut pas croître jusqu au ciel
le flux global dans lequel on s'inscrit
et en fait quand vous regardez bien
c'est déjà le cas depuis 2007 par
exemple la quantité de mètres carrés
construits en europe n'a plus augmenté
la quantité de tonnes contre charge dans
les camions n'a plus augmenté
donc si vous regardez ce qui relève
vraiment de la physique et pas de la
valorisation conventionnel en fait ça
n'augmente plus déjà depuis que le
pétrole européen s'est mis à décliner et
ça va s'accélérer malheureusement ou
heureusement je ne sais pas question de
point de vue dans dans l'est dans les
décennies à venir donc mon sentiment
c'est que le cadre intellectuel dans
lequel il faut qu'on raisonne c'est
celui là donc quand vous dites qu'elle
croissance c'est une nécessité ou c'est
une volonté sur un dépend pas de voir ce
que je suis en train de le dire c'est
sur une planète qui fait 13 morts
violentes
il ya une limite qui ne dépend pas de
nous c'est que la planète fait treize
mille kilomètres de diamètre qu'elle
faisait treize mille kilomètres de
diamètre ya deux siècles et dans ce
siècle sera toujours 13 mille kilomètres
de diamètre et que par ailleurs notre
économie est une économie minière c'est
à dire qu'elle repose sur l'extraction
et la la la mise à la poubelle d'un
certain nombre de ressources non
renouvelables commencer par les
hydrocarbures mais aussi les stocks de
forêt qu'on exploite de manière non
renouvelables la potasse reçoit les
minerais et que c'est très facile de moi
je fais des montres et s'armer étudiants
tous les ans c'est très facile de
montrer mathématiquement ce truc que ce
truc là ne peut pas engendrer une
croissance indéfinie
c'est possible arithmétiquement ça se
démontre assez simplement aller la
décroissance ou plutôt la la contraction
la contraction figure je ne dis pas que
c'est toi une bonne nouvelle je dis que
c'est un cadre de réflexion imposé
d'accord ça s'impose à nous exactement
et ça a déjà commencé et donc temps que
l'on réfléchisse en se disant la
croissance va revenir comme notre cher
ami bruno le maire l'a dit au micro de
bfm ya pas très longtemps et indécent
c'est ça qui va payer la dette
on est en train de penser l'avenir dans
un cadre qui relève d' alice au pays des
merveilles
donc on perd son temps puisqu'on est en
train de penser l'avenir dans un cadre
qui ne peut pas arriver
jean marc jancovici merci on a bien
compris le cadre que vous avez posé
xavier ragot je dois vous des
intervenants nelson qui nous écrit marie
également allé en commençant mari qui
nous dit la croissance ne peut être la
réponse pour aujourd'hui et demain
il faut repenser l'ensemble de notre
système économique il n'est pas ni
vivable ni duras pensez vous que la
décroissance sera de notre fait ou
serait-elle simplement subi par la force
des choses je vois sourire jean marc
jancovici et nelson qui ajoute pourquoi
toujours parler de croissance et mettre
la croissance au centre des débats
et comme finalité ultime de nos
politiques voyez ça interpelle quand
même les les publics
la croissance dit nelson et
quantitativement limité et
qualitativement mauvaises avec des
problèmes de répartition
peut-on avoir un autre objectif
collectif plutôt qualitatif aller qui
commence à lui jean marc jancovici avec
vous sur cette offense est je crois que
c'est une notion suscite une forme
d'inquiétude la croissance ce que vous
dit tout à l'heure qu'il fallait parler
de contraction pour répondre à créer
morin c'était le mot contraction et
j'ajoute ce personnellement et on va pas
trop s'éloigner de la question qui est
posée initialement mais vous dites
décroissance contraction mille et un
milieu hausse de la démographie
galopante
lorsque sur la planète oui il ya
certainement une hausse de la
démographie aujourd'hui mais je le redis
la planète fait 13 8 kilomètres de
diamètre a ses limites et il faut voir
aujourd'hui que si l'essentiel de la
planète mange à sa faim
c'est aussi dû à l'avènement des
combustibles fossiles les combustibles
fossiles par exemple ont permis à la
productivité céréalière en france d'être
multiplié par cinq à six au sortir de la
dernière guerre mondiale
ça c'est les tracteurs les engrais et
les phytosanitaires c'est à dire le
pétrole et le gaz
par ailleurs aujourd'hui on utilise dans
les champs on a rompu le cycle du
phosphore et le cycle de l'azoté et le
cycle du potassium avant on allait faire
pipi et caca dans les chances comme ça
que les animaux de trait y faisait
pareil maintenant qu'on fait pipi et
caca dans les stations d'épuration ont
rétabli le cycle avec des engrais qui
sont fabriqués de manière minière les
engrais azotés sont faits et du gaz et
la potasse et le phosphore et le
potassium son talent par bateau de
quelques mines qui voilà donc on a une
agriculture minière aujourd'hui un aussi
quittant l'équipe fourmilière revient
donc là là
donc voilà donc la question la
démographie est aussi une question en
soi dans un monde durable je perds
complètement sûr qu'on puisse faire
tenir lui milliards d'individus
pour répondre à la question aujourd'hui
on sent bien en fait que les gens ils
ont une aptitude à ses ambivalences
vis-à-vis cette histoire de croissance
c'est à dire qu'ils en comprennent
intellectuellement les limites tout en
ne comprenant pas le fait que les
applications très concrètes d'une
société en contraction c'est que leur
fiche de paye diminue voilà enfin une
contraction économique
c'est ça que ça veut dire en pratique ça
veut dire qu avec la même quantité
d'heures de travail vous vous offrez
moins deux mètres carrés - de robes
moins de table - deux chaises et moins
de billets de cinéma quand on peut y
retourner après le vide donc c'est bien
ça que ça veut dire
alors est ce que c'est une catastrophe
pour autant je ne sais pas ce que je
sais c'est qu'on va essayer aussi de
project d'apporter une réponse très
concrète à cette affaire alors pourquoi
nous on pense aux six projets que toute
façon on n'aura pas le choix c'est je le
dis tout face je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure
en fait là j'ai aussi répondre à mon
voisin gauche la hausse du temps libre
c'est parce qu'on habille les machines
au travail à leur place si on n'avait
pas mis les machines au travail et de
place on aurait pas là où du temps libre
donc dans un monde où
l'approvisionnement énergétique se
contracte on va pas avoir plus de temps
en étant payé plus cher on va avoir
moins de temps en étant payé moins cher
pourquoi va bosser plus pour gagner
moins
c'est bien ça qui va se passer la
question c'est est ce que dans cette
société là on peut retrouver du sens
parce que c'est la seule contrepartie
qu'on peut offrir
dit autrement à partir du moment où les
gens vont de toute façon gagner moins la
seule bonne question pour moi c est ce
qu on leur offre une libération de
l'angoissé quant à l'avenir
certains disent bon très bien je gagne
moins mais au moins je sais que ça
s'arrête et et je sais que ça
m'empêchera pas de me loger et de manger
et c'est de tenir à mes enfants un
discours qui est tout n'est pas foutu et
de me projeter dans l'avenir avec des
projets c'est ça il me semble que c'est
ça le truc vraiment important je le
redis on va devoir le faire de gré ou de
force degré parce que quand on regarde
ce que signifie de lutter contre le
changement climatique
quand je vais sortir quelques
pourcentages mais ils sont à mon avis
éclairant les combustibles fossiles
aujourd'hui ses 80 % de ce qui fait
fonctionner la machinerie mondial donc
80% de la machinerie mondiale qui
harangue qui a suppléé notre corps
fonctionne avec du pétrole du gaz et du
charbon
cette énergie prend l'atmosphère pour
une grande poubelle en y mettant du
dioxyde de carbone qui est un gaz qui va
provoquer du réchauffement climatique
ce réchauffement climatique a le
potentiel pour faire très court s'il se
monte à 4 ou 5 degrés en un siècle
en gros de tuer la moitié de la
population et de faire que l'autre
moitié vivra dans un monde désolé dont
on ne voudrait pas pour nous mêmes 1
mais c'est ça qu'on est en train de
préparer pour nos gosses c'est un autre
on est en train de parler alors si on
veut pas ça il faut que la quantité de
combustible fossile qu'on utilise dans
le monde baisse de 5% par an donc tous
les ans 5 % de moins que l'année
précédente ce qui est à peu près ce
qu'on va avoir en 2020 à cause du coc
vide mais il faut il faut d'accord la
physique vous dit deux degrés c'est ça
d'accord vous faites pas ça vous avez
plus de 2 degrés c'est physique
ça dépasse et c'est communément admise
est communément connue sauf que pour
être très taquin vos confrères le
vulgaris très peu mais c'est
parfaitement connu dans le monde est de
plus en plus un je vous rassure oui mais
enfin ça donne moins serrés entre et ça
devrait faire la finale de france info
et france inter un peu plus souvent avec
sais pas ce que c'est que vous avez
raison parce que c'est considérablement
plus impactants pour l'avenir des
français que de savoir qui va remplacer
edouard philippe mangou est rassuré mais
qui consomme beaucoup d'énergie savoir
cette chose-là qui ne changent pas
vraiment le corps et noranda on passe
beaucoup trop temps médiatique à des
discussions de bistrot qu'on peut tenir
au bistrot très bien et en plus c'est
plus sympa et pas assez à nous occuper
des vrais sujets de fond qui cadre très
très fortement nous degré de liberté
pour l'avenir
donc le donc 5% de moins par an ça veut
dire une société qui est physiquement en
contraction
donc la croissance verte c'est comme
dundee une petite chanson pour enfants
c'est comme une fourmi de 18 m avec un
chapeau sur la tête ça n'existe pas donc
non ça n'existe pas xavier ragot est pas
d'accord
j'attends la démonstration mathématique
que ça existe pour le moment je n'ai
jamais vu par contre moi je suis capable
de vous démontrer que ça n'existe pas
donc le mais c'est pas très grave donc
au chiffrage est en allant et pardon ici
on ne veut pas de toute façon la
contraction du pétrole du gaz et du
charbon est imposé par la géologie en
europe la contraction du charbon a
démarré dans les années 60 parce que ça
fait deux siècles comptable dans le
charbon le pic de production du charbon
en grande bretagne et 1914 la
contraction du gaz a démarré en 2005
année où la mer du nord a passé son pic
de production et la contraction du
pétrole a démarré en 2006 c'est à dire
le moment où la planète a passé son pic
de production sur le pétrole
conventionnel dix concerts
donc quoi qu'on fasse en europe de toute
façon notre approvisionnement fossiles
il est parti à la baisse donc de toutes
façons la croissance verte en europe on
oublie n'y aura pas de croissance mais
alors j'ai fini au chief project on a
lancé un programme dont on va rendre les
premières copies à la rentrée qui est
qu'est ce qu'on propose comme à venir
aux français dans un monde dans lequel
il faut décarbonés l'économie degré
parce que toute façon sinon ça se fera
de force dans un contexte
considérablement plus douloureux et dans
un contexte dans lequel notre premier
sujet c'est pas la dette publique on
s'en fout complètement ses longs doigts
dit autrement la praye ressource rare
c'est la physique et l'emploi et si on
essaie d'optimiser l'usagé de ces vraies
ressources rares c'est à dire les gens
qui bossent et les ressources physiques
qu'on à disposition comment est-ce qu'il
faut transformer la société
où sont les gagnants et les perdants
alors et ckoi de gens de métier qu'on
aura besoin de faire demain réponses oui
non avant de passer la parole à xavier
ragot et que et morin jean marc
jancovici si on ne fait rien c'est comme
dans ravages de barjavel c'est le crash
alors je sers est je sais pas si ça va
s'arrêter comme dans ravages de barjavel
par contre c'est un monde dans lequel
vous avez un délitement progressif et de
temps en temps des marches d'escalier
qui sont franchies avec des crises d'un
anticipée alors xavier ragot je vous ai
vue ouïe immigrés jeu maugrey parce que
je suis d'accord avec 99 % de ce que dit
jean marc jancovici et c'est sur la
dimension physique sur forcément il faut
consommer moins de ressources naturelles
forcément il faut décarbonés l'économie
tout ça c'est une certitude et jean marc
jancovici ont validé sa sauce musique
mais de 1% d'après on saute dans
l'économie où là je comprends plus du
tout ce sont 130 ap
là il faut pas faire croire que la
croiser fin et je pense qu'il ya un
enjeu mais je dirais quand même un enjeu
pour réussir la transition écologique un
enjeu de redéfinir la croissance il faut
pas laisser la croissance au
productiviste qu'est ce que je veux dire
par là et je veux insister là dessus
parce qu'on se trompe de débat c'est
quoi la croissance pour l'économiste
c'est la valeur des choses simplement
passion la valeur des choses c'est quoi
l'augmentation la valeur des choses
c'est les gens qui décident valeur des
choses sur leur valeur l'histoire du
capitalisme c'est une histoire de
l'abstraction la croissance au départ
c'était la reproduction physique
l'agriculture ensuite c'était bien
vêtements matériel et l'émancipation des
femmes avec le frigo et le machine à
laver cas permis l'émancipation des
femmes et dans la troisième période du
capitalisme l abstraction de ça vient
avec le service attendez attendez donc
la question cru
al c'est d'accélérer la traction de la
croissance et devrait définir ce qu'on
appelle la croissance la croissance
c'est quoi la croissance à la culture
la croissance est en bonne santé la
croissance a biodiversité
je vous assure que si vous mettez un
prix soit biodiversité et que vous
maximiser la lacroix centièmes du
meilleur site et vous allez par une
croissance économique parce que la bio
dire qu'il va s'accroître et la valeur
des choses restent à croire l'erreur de
la base de fin jeudi raid des noms
économie c'est de penser que l'économie
ce qui maximise la croissance du pipe
c'est un non sens absolu le but de
l'économie le seul but de l'économie
c'est celui qui a défini claude morin
c'est le bien-être et la croissance à
maxime à sion du bien-être la croissance
à ma création du bien-être la croissance
n'est pas la pollution c'est pas
l'obscurantisme
sanou de redéfinir le bien-être et quel
est mon problème là dedans parce que là
je trouve que je suis totalement
d'accord avec jean marc jancovici mon
petit problème sa chose suivante c'est
je suis un peu perdue jeudi qu' il n'y a
pas de crise sociale pour moi une crise
politique une crise de représentation
politique et je pense la convention
citoyenne c'est une avancée importante
pour ça parce que quand même qu'on prend
du recul attendait trump n'a pas été lu
molson a rose n'a pas été lui boris
johnson n'a pas été lu les frères
kaczinsky n'auront pas été élu huit en
or bas n'a pas été élu kiss-in ping n'a
pas énormément de soutien en chine mon
problème c'est pas du tout
l'impossibilité d'imposer au capital la
conscience environnementale
pour moi c'est trouver le moyen
politique pour convaincre et créer des
majorités pour le faire et je pense que
pour le faire il faut se battre non pas
en disant il faut sortir la croissance
au contraire il faut se battre pour une
redéfinition compatible avec les
collégiens net de la croissance
redéfinir des bons indicateurs de
croissance
il faut que pour moi il faut toujours se
battre pour la croissance mais sûre pour
la réinventer le redéfinir mois sans âme
extension bien ne pas l'abandonner parce
que je peur que les classes moyennes
classes moyennes inférieures
finalement si on oppose fin du monde fin
du mois et que c'est tara qui a des
mauvais réflexe au contraire il faut
rendre les deux compatibles et redéfinir
la croissance avec des bons indicateurs
de bien-être et l'alaska dick définit
comme brain une base indicateurs
d'authie travail eloi laurent et c'est
donc gardons la croissance mais
orientons d'humanité vers une bonne
direction qui est le bien-être la
biodiversité et la préservation des
ressources naturelles et morand est ce
que les hauts-fonds l'opinion publique
croit aujourd'hui encore et il ya
d'autres messages je vais vous en faire
part de d'un ou deux au passage croire
encore à cette notion de
2 de croissance est ce que si je faisais
un mix énergétique entre ce que
messieurs jancovici et xavier ragot on
dit est ce qu'on ne pourrait pas parler
désormais de deux contractions verte
écologique pour aller vers plus de bên
être clos et alors je pense qu'une des
questions c c'est exactement ça c'est
qu'elles sont donne à l'avenir donc
c'est vraiment en fait tous notre sujet
c'est vraiment un sujet de politique
avant avant même d'être un sujet
économique et mêmes techniques physiques
toute la question c'est que on raconte à
tout le monde depuis des années voire
des décennies que la croissance c'est le
synonyme de du progrès et forcément
quand on leur dit il va falloir vivre
dans un monde sans croissance il ya une
forme de panique
du coup ça pose vraiment un problème sur
comment est-ce qu'on pose les débats
pour créer du consensus
ou en tout cas des compromis qui
permette de cheminer vers un avenir qui
soit désirable ou en tout cas qu'il soit
pas perçue comme comme une punition
et comme et comme une régression et de
ce point de vue là j'ai l'impression
mais j'aimerais bien avoir la réaction
des deux autres débats temps c'est en
gros j'ai l'impression qu'on pose mal lé
débat dans le débat public
alors il ya peut-être une responsabilité
des médias mais je pense que c'est plus
large il y a la responsabilité d'aider
des politiques
j'ai l'impression que et y notamment ces
jours-ci d'ailleurs c'est assez frappant
on a bon hein
est-ce de clivage qui s'installe qui dit
d'un côté il ya la croissance verte pro
business en gros et puis de l'autre côté
il y aurait les décroissants malthusien
punitif
je pense que c'est la pire manière de
poser ce débat que c'est empêche de
penser et du coup je me disais il c'est
plus une question d'ailleurs je pense
qu'une des questions majeures pour les
années qui viennent c'est comment faire
en sorte de mieux poser débat pour que
les gens soient entraînés en a changé
alors débat mal posé
dites vous et vous avez sans doute
raison chloé morin je vous lis ce que
nous a écrit aurélien aurélien qui dit à
la réception de la convention citoyenne
pour le climat emmanuel macron jeudi au
passage qui est en train de commencer
sur l'opération de de remaniement
ministériel emmanuel macron a déclaré si
nous produisons moins nous travaillons
moins et nous ne pourrions plus financer
c'est une citation du chef de l'état le
modèle social qui est le nôtre on voit
bien a dit emmanuel macron que le choix
de la décroissance n'est pas une réponse
au défi climatique aurélien nous
demandent qu'en pensez vous j'ajoute
puisque l'on parle de politique publique
de réorientation de la production de
l'idée de croissance que vous évoquez
avec brio tous les trois ma question à
moi aussi je compléterai le propos
d'aurélien c'est comment anticiper au
fond comment ne pas aller là où on nous
pousse à dire ce que nous produisons est
ce que ce qui nous détruit au passage
j'ai presque envie de rappeler que
l'humanité a toujours progressé à coups
de catastrophe
donc allez on commence par vous jean
marc jancovici
comment est-ce que qu'est ce que vous
pensez d'abord de cette vision de
travailler - non pas question
on ne peut plus financer le modèle
social donc quelque part resté sur le
même rail et essayer de s'en sortir
coûte que coûte quoi qu'il en coûte
avant de répondre à votre question je
vais répondre à mon voisin de gauche
si votre voisin de gauche qui exhale
virago installé à votre gauche ça s'est
mis d'accord avec lui en fait
aujourd'hui la croissance un contenu
normatif
parce que le pib à une définition
normative si on se met d'accord pour
donner un contenu normatif à autre chose
qu'on veut faire croître je suis très en
phase avec ce que vous avez dit d'accord
j'ai aucun problème
moi j'ai pris le débat demeure scolaire
c'est à dire aujourd'hui quand on parle
de croissance croissance du pib et le
pib ayant un contenu normatif jeudi
certes sur ce contenu normatif là si on
décide de lui donner un autre contenu
normatif et donc par exemple de mettre
de raisonner en actif passif et dans les
actifs je colle la biodiversité climat
etc
on retombe sur ce que kenneth boulding
avait très bien dit il ya 50 ans c'est à
dire qu'à ce moment en maximiser la
production au sens où on l'entend
aujourd'hui c'est de la décroissance ou
deux je suis d'accord il ça donc il
suffit de donner un autre contenu
normatif au à l'objet du débat et à ce
moment on va s'entendre
la deuxième chose que je veux dire c'est
pourquoi est-ce que le ont tout à
l'heure évoquées par claude haymoz un
sûr on a présenté la croissance comme
une bonne chose qui a fait ça mais
l'essentiel des économies cependant très
longtemps et encore aujourd'hui un peu
les dents et l'oméga donc donc dont
xavier ragot il est plutôt un ovni dans
les économies ce que j'ai l'habitude
d'entendre la majeure partie d'entre eux
disent la croissance est une très bonne
chose et du reste c'est pour ça que il
faut continuer à la voir et avec le
contenu normatif actuelle ces récentes
eu payé
le troisième raison pour laquelle le
monde politique l'adorent et ça y est
c'est induits dans la question qui a été
posée en fait c'est que le p le pib
c'est la base fiscale
en fait il faut bien voir que
l'essentiel de nos prélèvements
obligatoires c'est une fraction du pib
les salaires c'est une fraction du pib
l'impôt sur le revenu des entreprises
c'est une fraction du passé prélevé sur
une fraction du pib la tva c'est prélevé
sur une fraction du pib l'athée icpe
donc la taxe sur les carburants
donc en fait ils pib se contracte la
base fiscale se contracte et comme le
monde politique
il n'a en démocratie confère tocqueville
comme comme discours électoral que de
vendre durable de sucettes un monde dans
lequel la quantité de sucettes à
distribuer baisse et n'ont pas augmenté
ils sont à poil devant ils n'ont pas de
discours prêt pour ce genre de trucs et
ils ont pas le grand projet enthousiaste
datant de l'époque des planificateurs
qui en gros est morte avec les gens
issus de la dernière guerre ils n'ont
aucune capacité enthousiasmé les foules
sur un discours planificateur ils ont
tous un discours de boutiquiers macro on
nous parle du défi fou du déficit public
enfin aller parler aux gens que vous
croisez dans la rue
or dans le grand projet de la france et
de baisser le déficit public est ce que
ça vous excite
vous regardez comme si vous pariez
grecque tout le monde tourne sans fiche
allégeance à laissac ça car ça vous dit
quel métier vous allez faire cela
diminue déficits publics non ça vous dit
comment vous allez levez vos enfants que
vous allez manger ce soir
est ce que ça vous dit rien c'est un
truc de de nantis parisien discuter du
déficit public mais c'est pas du tout un
truc qui parle aux gens donc je suis
très d'accord aussi avec ce qu'a dit
chloé morin on a un vrai problème de
déficit politique dans cette histoire
qui est un déficit de projet quand
kennedy a enthousiasmé les gens en
disant on va aller sur la lune ce qui
soit dit en passant demander plus
d'énergie il a vendu un projet qui
n'était pas un projet économique
quand de gaulle disait l'intendance
suivra il vendait des projets qui
n'étaient pas écoliers avant son départ
de rêve mais qui emporte l'adhésion de
tous c'est ça c'est à dire en gros il
faut vendre un défi il faut vendre un
projet faut vendre quelque chose qui
s'incarne dans le quotidien qui
s'incarne dans le concret et aujourd'hui
on a un vrai déficit là dessus et je
vais finir sur les médias parce que tout
à l'heure je dis c'est pas juste un
problème de médias a dit chloé mais je
pense quand même que les médias ont une
grande part de responsabilité je vais
vous prendre un exemple très concret qui
contre ça les conventionnels de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat il
ya une question que tous vos confrères
devra leur poser une seule qui ait
toutes les mesures que vous proposez
aujourd'hui quelle est la part d'entre
elles où vous auriez été à titre
personnel opposé il ya huit mois
d'accord et si maintenant vous êtes
favorable alors que vous étiez opposé
qu'est ce qui vous a fait changer d'avis
et moi je peux vous donner une partie de
la réponse
elle dit les a fait changer d'avis et de
découvrir le problème à traiter donc
tant que vous n'avez pas une idée claire
de l'ampleur du défi vous n'avez aucune
envie de la pédagogie et il faut faire
même si ça comporte une part à peu
désagréable la pédagogie du problème à
traiter
sinon les gens et tourne en rond mais il
vous devenez pas l'impression encore un
mot avec vous jean marc jancovici que
cette pédagogie je ne dis pas ça pour
défendre ma boutique médiatique assez
pâle ce pas le but mais je suis mauvaise
moi aussi un consommateur de média et
est autre que ce que les choses
progressent et tous trop lentement
on est dans une posture lattes lentement
on est dans une course contre la montre
je le répète
et si on doit répéter chaque année la
baisse d'émissions qu'on a là n'est due
qu'au vide vous comprenez bien que on
est plus proche de l'économie guerre et
du plan d'urgence que du de la gentille
progression lente où on continue quand
même à ouvrir les 20 heures sur des
chiens écrasés
on a quand même un sujet à ce niveau
xavier ragot sur ce qu'avait dit
aurélien ce citation de 10 magnenat cran
autour d'eux
la croissance finalement il ne faut pas
aller vers moins de croissance qu'on ne
pourra plus financer le modèle social
etc
est ce que vous n'avez pas l'impression
qu'il ya ces normes que définissez à
l'instant jean marc jancovici cette
espèce de doxa finalement on est
toujours sur la même lecture des choses
les politiques les politiques publiques
mais en même temps le monde réel qu'est
ce que c'est c'est d'un côté une très
grande pauvreté qui va galopant et de
l'autre allez au hasard les transactions
financières qui se paie de bulle
artificielle richissime et au fond au
milieu il y aurait une règle qui qui qui
qui contraindrait le la grande partie de
l'immense majorité des gens au quotidien
on n'en sort pas qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour aller vers peut-être plus de
nom pas de décroissance mais de
contraction plus de réel et sortir de ce
de ce rail delà de la croissance telle
qu'elle est définie par rapport au pib
comment on en sort c'est comment on en
sort c'est une grande question c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris pour moi vous avez
bien compris c'est que et on s'en va
finir d'être d'accord avec jean marc
jancovici impressionnant d'ailleurs même
encore plus loin je fait un peu brutale
je m'excuse j'aime pas faire ça en fait
mon vrai métier si je suis directeur de
recherche au cnrs chercheur j'ai des
thésards et ses agences à une économie
quand une personne vous dit que le but
de l'économie c'est de maximiser le pibe
c'est pas un économiste
n'importe quel économiste vous dira que
le but des économies c'est le bien-être
pour moi c'est fort simple quand je vois
dans les plateaux télé je vois les gens
il ya les économies ce n'est pas
l'économiste
le but est maximisée le bien-être c'est
quoi le bien-être je sais pas ce que
c'est c'est des gens qui choisissent
leur propre définition du bien-être par
le départ les interactions de la chambre
c'est essentiel de rappeler ça que le
but de l'économie n'a jamais était de
maximiser le pibe sinon si
l'instrumentation politique des
économistes pour la raison que vous avez
dit alors j'ai élaboré m'attend comment
sortir de cette vision des choses
extrêmement rigide et effectivement que
médicaux est mort en impression qui a
pas d'autres systèmes
c'est pour ça que dans mon introduction
j'ai pris l'histoire du mouvement social
et du gua ouvriers et la lettre cette
façon dont est traité le gant à traiter
de cette question sociale c'était
exactement la même chose
vous reprenez il y avait tout il y avait
la notion de propriété la notion
d'efficacité des valeurs morales etc
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé ces
différents mouvements avec le mouvement
syndicaliste avec le mouvement
l'évolution du parti politique le moins
républicain avec avec les moins
religieux le crédit social explique star
qui a fait que la société a avancé
moi ce que je vois c'est comment on va
trouver et quelle est la part de
responsabilité de chacun pour faire
avancer et former des coalitions
politiques stables pour changer de
capitalisme moi j'ai deux craintes
j'ai une crainte qui est que le problème
soit mal posée et qui est une course de
poursuite aujourd'hui avec des projets
de droit d'extême droite souverainiste
qui ont le vent en poupe au niveau
international et puis un autre projet
alternatif qui sera défini autour la
question écologique et sociale
jean marc jancovici actifs project en
fait partie dans le monde associatif il
ya des expressions politiques dont on a
vu la semaine dernière la question pour
chacun les médias moi je suis pas à dire
ça faut des médias j'y crois pas eva
jeux peuvent dévalorise autre métier
mais vous vous êtes vous exprimer des
attentes sociales qu'on va dans les
audimats si jamais la question
écologique intéresser les gens les
médias irait le problème c'est que ça
n'intéresse pas les gens comment éduquer
les gens on a tous notre part de
responsabilité en tant qu'économie c'est
quoi ma part de responsabilité c'est un
rappelé que le rôle des économies c'est
pas maxime et le pim et notre rôle je
pense c'est devrait contribuer à
redéfinir de manière normative la
croissance est là il ya une tension avec
les avec parmi des écologistes c'est par
exemple le prix du carbone est-ce qu'on
ait une prix du tableau carbone avec une
taxe carbone est ce qu'on utilise les
outils de marché pour mettre des matelas
convaincu par par ces pistes là si je
suis je suis plutôt convaincu mais je
pense que le débat est ouvert parce que
c'est un débat complexe parce qu'il ya
un courant des écologistes qui dit qu'il
faut pas mettre des prix parce que ces
marchandises et la nature c'est
dangereux il ya notre courant qui dit
qu'il faut mettre des prix parce que ça
permet de faire la vérité elle est
chaude et changer le fonctionnement des
coûts de marché je suis plutôt pour le
second
quand j'ai vu l'histoire du la question
sociale histoire de mauvrit y est je
pense qu'il faut assumer le fait que la
biodiversité en mettant une valeur
économique dessus pour redéfinir la
l'économie avec cette variante donc
réinventons notion de valeur qui met un
prix la biodiversité dans nos agrégats
économiques et xavier ragot questions
courtes réponses courtes si vous pouvez
hollywood où nous demanda l'instant vous
ne croyez absolument pas la quatrième
révolution industrielle telle que
théorisée par davos du coup mais que
vous y croyez vous y croyez pas enfin ça
c'est un peu des mots c'est là c'est la
diffusion des outils numériques pour les
optimisation énergétique intimidation
sociale oui on bien sûr que j'y crois et
c'est pas une révolution c'est pas une
révolution c'est une évolution c'est une
évolution c'est important ça veut dire
qu'on peut utiliser
la technologie manière intelligente pour
la question environnementale ça on peut
le faire il faut le faire mais la
question c'est qu'il faut trouver
imposer des réglementations pour le
faire alors il nous reste six minutes
avant le terme
donc vous avez si je calcul bien deux
minutes chacun à peu près je vous
couperait un club morin quelle
croissance de demain c'est la question
qui était posée au départ cet échange
était très enrichissant qu'est ce que
vous diriez vous c'est le bien-être
c'est l'économie c'est le but
d'économiser l'instant xavier ragot
c'est le bien-être
oui je pense qu'en fait les solutions
existent probablement on en est une
démonstration moi j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant
je pense que la plus grande difficulté
qu'on aura les démocratique
elle est politique elle est à la fois
notre capacité à débattre
je prends un ce sujet pour faire très
vite mais le nucléaire par exemple on a
l'impression que chaque fois qu'on met
l'eau hier quelque part les gens se
faire à chacun rentre dans sa tranchée
ce pays qui est qui plus est il ya plus
de possibilités de de débattre donc la
solution me semble que c'est dans la
retrouver la capacité de débattre de
tous les sujets y compris ceux qui sont
devenus des espèces de deux totems ou de
religion et retrouver des visions que
l'un des responsables politiques qui
arrive à embarquer derrière des visions
effectivement qui donne un sens à un
autre sens à à la croissance prêtent
petit petit ajout pour vous vous reste
un peu de temps répondez à pascal qui
nous demandent que pensez vous claude
morin tient de l' indice de bonheur
national brut du bhoutan un indice de ce
type serait t'il selon vous qu est
envisageable dans les sociétés
européennes le bonheur national brut le
bnp bnb pardonnez moi on a tendance en
france à être fasciné par ces indices là
parce que généralement en fait
sur 2010 on est le pays le plus
pessimiste du monde donc ailleurs j'ai
pas d'avis particulier l'accord lundi
être intéressant mais chut je note qu'on
a on a un un pessimisme et un déclinisme
qui nous sont propres qui sont sans
doute liées à la question précédente
d'absence de vision politique
voilà vous avez puisé votre temps
philippe clair nous écrit qui dit
croissance dit pib dit énergie l'énergie
devenant plus incertaine et les urgences
climatiques plus prégnante
n'est-il pas le moment d'adjoindre au
pib conventionnelle actuels un pib non
conventionnelles non viables et
acceptables répondants ça fait
efficacement aux enjeux sociétaux et
planétaire jean marc jancovici vous avez
presque deux minutes pour nous dire
quelle croissance demain à vos yeux
moi je vais le dire autrement le pib
était un très bon indicateur pour
représenter le boeuf encore dire le
progrès dans un monde infini pourquoi
parce que dans un monde infini les
ressources que vous commencez à prélever
pour faire des fourchettes et des tables
ne gêne pas les stocks résiduels parce
que vous prélèvements sont très faibles
par rapport à l'immensité des stocks et
le fait de servir de l'environnement
comme une poubelle n'est pas un problème
non plus parce que vaut rejet sont très
faibles par rapport à l'immensité de
l'environnement donc pour reprendre ce
qui a été dit tout à l'heure par xavier
ragot vous n'avez pas besoin de passer
des dotations aux amortissements sur les
stocks non renouvelable et vous n'avez
pas besoin de passer des provisions pour
risques pour dommages environnementaux
donc vous pouvez au premier ordre
ignorez tout ce qui relève de
l'environnement en disant c'est pas
touché par mes activités je vais créer
des truc en plus qui sont très sympas
des immeubles dans lesquels j'habite etc
j'ai pas de trucs en moins j'ai pas
besoin de m'en occuper
maintenant qu'on est 8 milliards et que
l'on consomme trop consomme on peut plus
raisonner comme ça et donc on est dans
un problème d'arbitrage dans lequel un
peu plus de fourchette et d'immeubles se
paye de un peu moins d'air pur et de
biodiversité et de sécurité et de
stabilité pour l'avenir
bon et donc il faut qu'on fasse des
choix donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
faut prendre les gens pour des adultes
et être capable d'éclairer ses choix et
je trouve que l'exercice de la
convention citoyenne de ce point de vue
est très intéressant parce que vous
prenez des gens presque ordinaire il ya
eu un petit biais de dépistage parce que
ceux qui voulaient vraiment pas venir on
les a pas forcé à venir
oui ça a été compliqué oui mais vous
prenez des gens presque ordinaire et
vous voyez qu'en fait ils font un
arbitrage qui consiste à se dire on
accepte l'idée concert un peu la
ceinture aujourd'hui
parce que ça stabilise la société et ça
nous donne de l'air et de la perspective
est l'indicateur suis en fait c'est un
indicateur ne précède pas ce genre de
choix
l'indicateur c'est juste une manière de
piloter le changement une fois qu'on a
décidé de quatre changements on avait
envie et il faut un arbitrage ces jeux
vous je vous cite en évoluant
éventuellement sur telle ou telle option
une fois qu'ils sont informés qu on peut
pas arbitré tant qu'on n'a pas compris
où on était allé la conclusion avec vous
également xavier ragot
il faut d'autres indicateurs mais après
en tant qu' en fin je dirais qu'il faut
pas croire que l'indicateur résumé la
politique je pense qu'il faut 18 10
discuter de construire d'autres
indicateurs et la partie intéressante à
le débat pour savoir ce qu'on met dedans
et peut-être que la génération suivante
à mettre autre chose dans l'indicateur
donc il ya dans cette question
d'indicateurs il faut pas se faire avoir
c'est parce que le bib était dominant
qu'on est le pitch un très mauvais
indicateur pourquoi c'est quoi le peep
s'est produit intérieur brut
enfin faut il rappeler aux gens c'est
quoi le brut
le brut ça veut dire que dans le pire on
tient pas compte la destruction du
capital la production tout économiste le
sait sa base la comptabilité nationale
l'indicateur pipe par définition ne
tient pas compte la destruction de
capital donc à minima il faut prendre le
prologue du produit intérieur net qui
tient compte l'instruction de capital
notamment des du capital des ressources
naturelles ça en tant qu'économie sont
là des miliaires d'indicateurs celui là
ça a été l'objet d'un consensus
politique dans les airs productiviste
entre les partenaires sociaux pour
négocier les fruits de la croissance
à billancourt il ne faut pas l'oublier
c'est un objet politique le pibe donc la
question qui nous est posée
soit on essaie de construire un autre
indicateur soit on essaie d'avoir
plusieurs indicateurs pour laisser le
débat politique définir c'est quoi notre
futur qu'on veut pour nous et notre
notre génération il faut ouvrir le débat
politique indicateurs le débat c'est pas
un substitut au débat politique
merci à tous les trois jean marc
jancovici président du think tank de
shift project passionnant ce que vous
nous avez appris tous aujourd'hui xavier
ragot éclairant président de l'ufc
l'observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques l'om aura un politologue
associé à la fondation jean jaurès co
fondatrice du blog nos lendemains et
membres d informer de france info et
merci à toutes celles et tous ceux et
mais compris ce que je n'ai pas cité de
nous avoir écrit et d'avoir participé à
cette passionnante réunion
merci à tous et bonne journée
balla
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]